how does this happen I thought the whole
idea with crypto was that only you had
the key and nobody could take your money
if they didn't have it so how did it
disappear
well the point here is that people left
their um their cryptocurrency on a
centralized exchange and we don't want
that we want people to actually take
self-custody and not leave it on these
centralized exchanges particularly one
actually like FTX there's a lot of weird
things happening so the media is
actually still actually gushing over FTX
the New York Times made um this puff
piece which um said how sandbachman
freed how is crypto Empire collapsed why
not actually say well how this
individual stole billions of dollars
from the average person well obviously
they're not going to say that why
because FTX was actually becoming the
crypto arm of the establishment Sam
bankman freed was working very closely
with Regulators the SEC Gary ginsler the
chairman of the SEC to establish this
regulatory Monopoly over the entire
Market completely um ousting all forms
of competitors also snapbackman free
pads are the likes of Bill Clinton and
Tony Blair speak at his crypto
conference I said this was a red flag
Bill Clinton obviously that speaks for
himself but Tony Blair he was the prime
minister of the United Kingdom and
should be in jail for war crimes because
of his involvement in the Iraq War he's
very Pro cbdc's and he's very Pro
digital IDs and covered lockdowns so
it's very bizarre that a crypto person
like sambang than freed would endorse
such people like that sound back me
freed is also a member of the world
economic Forum FTX had a page at the
world economic forum and as you
mentioned earlier he was actually the
second largest donator to uh Biden's
presidential campaign all very very
bizarre stuff also if you have a look at
the FTX website you can actually see
that Ukraine has been sending millions
of dollars to FTX who then send millions
and billions of dollars to The
Establishment who then sent billions of
dollars to Ukraine so it's like this
weird Circle going on here it's all very
very bizarre and um the lesson that we
learn here is do not trust centralized
entities do not leave your
cryptocurrency on an exchange you must
always take self-custody which means
removing it from these exchanges like
FTX who we really can't trust and
actually putting it on a non-custodial
wallet where you only hold the keys
so I gotta run but just quickly you
don't your faith in crypto is in shaken
it's just your faith in exchanges am I
right
oh absolutely um and I think it's really
important to check out who the exchanges
are working with and who they're
donating money to it's very clear that
FTX was very much um in bed with the
establishment in bed with the world
economic forum and promoting uh ideas
and ethoses which are very much against
um what we stand for um in the
cryptocurrency community and what
Bitcoin stands for decentralization and
very anti-establishment
Leia Halpern thanks a lot for your time
we appreciate it
thanks so much for having me